encuentran la probabilidad de obtener
solo números pares en tres tiros
consecutivos de un dado de seis caras
numeradas del 1 al 6 así que es un dado
perfectamente normal primero lo que
vamos a hacer es encontrar la
probabilidad de obtener obtener un
número par número par
en un solo tiro en un tiro
ok vamos a encontrar primero esta
probabilidad y bien como la encontramos
pues que nos puede pasar se arrojamos un
dado nos puede salir uno o dos o tres o
cuatro o cinco o seis tienes seis caras
nuestro lado y de esos seis eventos
cuales satisfacen la condición de ser un
número par pues sólo el 2 el 4 y el 6
así que tengo tres eventos favorables de
entre seis eventos posibles así que esta
probabilidad es tres sextos o lo que es
lo mismo es un medio bien entonces si
ahora consideramos la probabilidad la
probabilidad de obtener
obtener solo
pared
en tres tiros
pues entonces yo sé que cada tiro es
independiente el tiro que haga no afecta
para nada el tiro siguiente a veces la
gente cree que este no es el caso la
falacia del apostador que les contaba el
otro día pero esto sí son eventos
independientes de modo que yo sé que la
probabilidad de obtener son los números
pares va a ser igual a
la probabilidad de obtener un número par
en el primer tiro
multiplicada por la probabilidad de
obtener un número par en el segundo tiro
x
por la probabilidad de obtener un número
par en el tercer tiro ahora bien cuánto
es esto pues la probabilidad de obtener
un número par en el primer tiro es de un
medio es este un medio que ya calculamos
así que esto es un medio por un número
par en el segundo tiro que de nuevo es
un medio por un número par en el tercer
tiro que de nuevo es un medio un medio
por un medio por un medio que es un
octavo tenemos un chance entre 8 de
sacar solo números pares en tres tiros
de nuestro lado